how do the top 0.1% in the world
actually make more money than everyone
else there's three layers let's start
with layer one Global so if you zoom all
the way out the top 1% of countries in
the world do things differently than the
rest of them and we can measure the
productivity of a country by something
called GDP which is gross domestic
product per capita now the per capita
part just means how much total
production the economy does so just
think Revenue think sales and then per
capita is per person and so this allows
us to Norm ize different countries that
are big countries versus small countries
and see how much the individual is
making now the reason this is so
important and why we start at layer one
Global is because if you even out
everything you will be able to see the
strongest levers on wealth creation
because they're just done in Aggregate
and to be clear within each country of
course there are some people that get
way more of that slice of the pie than
others but even at the global level
there are some countries that get more
of the slice of the pie than other
countries and so for example the United
States has the largest GDP in the world
and tuvalu has the smallest now per
capita it shifts around Luxembourg is
actually the country in the world that
has the highest GDP per person so
151,000 now I'll give you an example of
number two which is Singapore they have
the second highest GDP per capita and is
also the home of uh Michael who's our
media director uh and the reason they
were able to do that is because they
invest these countries in two major
categories number one is education and
number two is technology and so if you
look at GDP P per capita for a country
the increases can almost directly be
tied by reinvestments in education and
Technology Singapore has
$148,000 in gross domestic product per
capita now how do they have that well
the entire culture in Singapore is
flipped compared to say the United
States teachers believe it or not there
are actually seen as one of the most
prestigious positions that you can hold
and they are paid very well because the
country understands that attracting good
teachers is one of the ways to make the
country more competitive long term and
so if we think about this at a global
level which I think is important is what
are the inputs that every country has
that's even the
inputs are
time and
bodies and so at the very basic level
someone anybody at all these countries
at level zero can do menial labor which
is basically things that have required
no skill to do so if I had a conveyor
belt of switchboards and I had to plug
two things in another one comes in I
plug two things in it's typically
something that you can train someone to
do in about five minutes and then you're
just basically having them trade their
time and doing this very simple task
repetitively now that is typically not
valued nearly as highly as other skills
which is why countries will invest in
technology and education the education
so that they have more skills take
technology to do three things technology
does number one it allows you to do more
of what you currently do so that
switchboard person if there wasn't a
conveyor Bel in front of them wouldn't
be able to do nearly as many of those
things as someone who did the second
thing is that technology allows you to
do what you can already do even better
and so think of both of those in terms
of units of time because remember this
is one of the key inputs that everybody
has that's even whether you're in the
richest country in the world or the
poorest country in the world every
single person has the same 24 hours and
yet some countries massively outcompete
other ones just like some individuals in
every individual economy massively
outcome people within them which will
peel back in Layer Two let's think about
it like this if you have a brain and two
hands then what allows you to do more
with that brain in two hands well
technology lowers the skill requirement
to do anything right like if you had to
figure out how to build a house but you
couldn't use tools you'd have to have a
tremendous amount of skills but all of a
sudden if you have a saw and you have uh
you know some Nails then you wouldn't
have to figure out how to like break
trees and interlock them and do all
sorts of craziness right that's at a
very basic level but on top of that it
allows you to do more of what you're
already doing so that means you're doing
more per unit of time remember
everything's going to be traced back to
time or you do higher quality which also
is traced back to time because maybe you
it would take you a longer period of
time to make something that good or
would just simply be impossible right
which is why it's such an advantage that
in the early days of smartphones and I
don't even know if they still do this
anymore but you're not allowed to use a
Smartphone when you take tests because
it's such an advantage that it shifts
the whole curve
which I think by the way they should
allow you to do that because that's how
the real world is and I think the point
of school is to prepare you for it and
so imagine you have two different sets
of people you've got 100 people on one
side and 100 people on the other and the
100 people on one side have electricity
Wi-Fi internet computers versus the
others don't well which one's going to
produce more economic value obviously
the one on the left not because these
people are inherently better than the
others they just have technology on
their side right and so we have to think
about ourselves from the country all the
way down using the same tools so at the
first layer the wealthiest people in the
world the 0.1% invest in gaining skills
buying technology or learning skills to
use that technology now if you're
hearing this you might think like I
would well cool that's great for them
but what about me so that enters into
Layer Two so let's zoom in on that what
are the skills that actually create the
production at the individual level so
instead of global now let's talk about
that per capita that person just like
you just like me now how do the 0.1%
actually create that gross domestic
product that gross production that
Revenue that then gets categorized for
the entire country well there are three
skills that I'll call BSL and then
they're multiplied by something that
I'll use as R and you're like what do
these all stand for well the first thing
category of skills is around building
you you make stuff you either build
Bridges you build software sometimes
building is putting together things so
that you can do services but you build
stuff the second
is you sell stuff the third is you lead
people and these also chunk up if you
want the fancier terms here to
Mechanical verbal and social skills so
these are the three overarching
categories that skill development as it
relates to GDP can get bubbled up to now
to be clear each of these skills are not
binary it's not oh you know how to build
oh you know how to sell oh you know how
to lead but it's how well can you build
how well can you sell and how well can
you lead and so with each of these they
create leverage they get you more for
what you put in specifically time
because if I build something then I can
have many people use it over and over
again if I learn how to sell I can sell
many people at once if I learn how to
lead I can get many people inside my
company to do many things on my behalf
and in each of these situations that one
person starts to accumulate the
aggregate production of everyone else
that touches either the thing they built
how they got people to exchange money
for it or the people that they were able
to lead to deliver and the outcome of
all of these things is the big thing
that everyone cares about which is money
now the longer that this lever gets
meaning if I get better and better at
building then more money happens on this
side if I get better and better at
selling more money happens on this side
if I get better and better at leading I
can pull this lever with more leverage
and get more money now what are the
richest people in the world world have
in common well not only do they have one
of these skills developed out a lot many
of them have all of these skills super
maxed out and the difficulty with this
drawing is that it's very hard to show
that maybe the average person's lever
looks like
this compared to what the richest people
the 0.1% actually make so let's zoom in
on some of the biggest financial success
stories of our time so if you look at
Zuckerberg for example who's the founder
of Facebook when he started he probably
mostly just had build skills but those
build skills were enough that eventually
he learned a little bit more about
promotion he built some promotion into
the product which allowed him to get
more more people on then over time he
developed leadership skills so that he
could lead the company and it's very
common that building and selling
happened in the beginning and then
leading develops over time because in
the beginning who are you going to be
leading besides yourself right not many
people and this skill naturally will
develop in time but it gives you more
leverage on the other two so let's get
tactical on build so in this book $100
million offers I talk about uh the
concept of trimming and stacking so it
starts with looking at all the different
problems that a customer presents with
and then thinking okay how many
different ways can I solve them and so I
use something called the delivery Cube
to say okay if we have this one problem
how can I solve this by thinking about
what level of personal attention I want
to provide what level of effort would be
expected from them if doing something
like what kind of environment or medium
do I want to solve this problem in do I
want how do I want these people to
consume my solution how quickly do I
want them to get response or get their
problem solved using my services or
product and then if I were to create a
product that was 10 times as expensive
what would that look like and if I had
to create a product that was on10th as
expensive but still had to produce the
same outcome how would I build that
instead and so this is a wonderful
framework that I like to think through
and also wondering is there a way that
we can psychologically solve a problem
rather than simply logically solve a
problem and Rory Sutherland talks about
this when uh he he explains that some
people used to complain about having
slow elevators you could either replace
the entire elevator system put a bigger
motor in and try and get people there
faster or you can just put mirrors in
the elevators and then people stare at
themselves and don't notice the time
pass and so that would be a
psychological rather than logical
solution because customers are by and
large illogical and so we want to make
sure that the solution that we have
solves the problem and sometimes it's
not even in the way that You' logically
expect now the way that this problem
solution cycle actually works which I
talk about in the leads book is that
you're going to have one problem they
present with and then you're going to
solve it and then what happens is that
creates yet another problem because
let's say that you uh solve someone's uh
hunger problem with a salty pretzel well
what problem comes up naturally well now
they're thirsty so then you solve that
with a glass of water or a soda and so
this this cycle continues and continues
and continues now once you've solved
those two problems what's the next
problem well now their dessert stomach
is empty so we have to present them with
a cookie right and so there's always if
you properly solve a problem for a
customer there's almost always another
problem that gets presented as a result
of the solution and the main reason for
that is because people are never
satisfied and so over the span of many
years a good Builder will develop an
ecosystem of products that solves many
customer issues at once so if you look
at Apple one of the most valuable
companies in the world if not the most
valuable is it's not just that they have
one product they've built an end to-end
ecosystem that's closed so that someone
can use just their products and solve
most of their digital needs they've got
a browser they've got computers they've
got a phone they have music where you
can buy the stuff everything is
interconnected but if you're like oh I'm
going to build that well that also took
them you know 50 years or however long
it's been so this stuff happens over
time so that covers build but what about
sell well selling is about the
perception of the prospect which is that
fundamentally you might have the best
product in the world but if they don't
perceive it to be the best product or
even know that it exists then there's no
way that they're ever going to use it
and so we want to make sure that we can
communicate that value to prospects
ideally at scale so the simplest lowest
leverage so think about this thing
shortening the lowest leverage version
of selling is selling 101 you sell
somebody in person you sell them via
chat you're just selling and you're
closing One customer at a time over time
you increase the leverage of sales by
either you selling more people at once
or getting through leadership which I'm
getting ahead of myself getting other
people to sell in your your behalf but
in either situation you gain more
leverage on the amount of people that
find out about your stuff and ideally
shift their perception of it so that
they want to buy it again and again and
again and when I talk about sell I
actually talk about everything that
takes someone from completely unaware to
giving you money all right so that's all
of acquisition so that's advertising
Marketing sales branding promotion and
conversion as in getting the person to
buy and so the easiest way or the most
important part of this is what I would
call the call out which is people
noticing your ad and when I say Ad I
mean what if you reach out to somebody
that's an advertisement you let people
know about your stuff is the most
important part and so I love this quote
by David Ogie he says after you've
written your headline you've spent 80
cents of your advertising dollar which
just goes to show that that first
impression is the part that one I test
the most and the one that will shift
their perception the most which is also
part of something called Framing and so
how you position again how people
perceive the reason the intro of a video
is so important the reason the intro of
an ad is so important the reason the
moment you introduce yourself how you
introduce yourself is so important is
because it frames everything else that
happens afterwards and so let's imagine
that you're at a cocktail party in a big
Ballroom lots of people talking groups
loud music playing in the background in
all that noise a single sound pierces
through it all and you turn around you
want to know the sound your name you
hear it and instantly look for the
source and so a call out is whatever you
do to get the attention of your audience
call outs go from hypers specific to get
one person's attention to not at all
specific to get everyone 's attention so
let me explain so if someone drops a
tray of dishes in that Ballroom everyone
looks if a child yells mom then all the
moms look if someone says your name then
only you look but again they all get
attention and so we want to make our
call outs specific enough to get the
right people and Broad enough to get as
many of them as we can and so with each
of these skills you will typically start
narrow and go broader Facebook when it
started as a product was very narrow and
then it just started with college
students and then it expanded to high
school students and then it started
going to adults right when you sell in
the beginning you're you're just going
to advertise to a very small niche as
clo you know as Tiny as you can mostly
because you can't compete in the ocean
you're you're not a big enough fish yet
but you can win in the tiny pond right
or maybe even a puddle but then over
time as you get better and bigger you
can expand the breath of the people that
you choose to Target and so you will
always convert a higher percentage not
absolute but percentage of an audience
by being more specific and so the
easiest way to figure out what your
customers want to hear when you're
advertising and selling to them is to
Simply ask them and if you want to be a
super Advanced student go look at user
reviews of all your competitors and
figure out the things they complain
about and then talk about those pain
points and the things that you want to
attract them with now the 0.1% know how
to build things then how to let people
know about it and get them to give them
money for it the second core skill here
which then leads us to the third skill
because once you're building and selling
and building and selling you're probably
going to need help and that enters into
leading so these are the social dynamics
theas reason I think leading is arguably
the most important skill besides
learning is that it is a meta skill it
gains you access to everyone else's
skills and so at its most basic form if
you were the best leader in the entire
world you would be able to get the best
builder and the best seller to come work
with you and align with your overall
objective I consider building selling
and leading to be the tripod of business
you must have all three they are the
tripod of business you must have all
three now you can be uh
imbalanced and have a stool that looks a
little bit weird but if you don't have
one of these legs this thing's going to
fall over and so you must have all three
now the extent to which you have all
three will dictate how much
money you're able to make so if you can
only sell and you can't
build and you can lead then you'd have a
bunch of people who are really good at
selling something terrible so this would
be like The Wolf of Wall Street's
business so what he went to jail for and
so that is basically lying at scale not
good if you just build and no one finds
out about it and you're good at leading
for example then you'll just have this
thing that's sitting in your garage that
you promise is amazing but no one knows
about it and so if no one knows about it
no one can buy it and on the third
extreme and this is why this one's a
little bit more interesting is that if
you could lead and somehow you found a
bunch of people that no one in the
organization knew how to sell or build
this is why this is a meta skill then
well really nothing would happen because
you'd have nothing to build and no one
would find out about it and you just
have a lot of people that were somehow
organized around doing nothing and so
these are the core things that actually
generate the activity the leadership
aligns those activities in One Direction
so fundamentally every single time
you're considering bringing someone into
an organization and this is what we're
thinking about like either you are the
person getting brought into the
organization or you the person that owns
the organization but we're talking about
the 0.1 wealthiest percent of people and
this is how they think which is that
every new person needs to support either
selling more people or making them worth
more through making the product better
because the sad truth of it is that
every new hire is a guaranteed cost but
is not a guaranteed return and so unless
they are building or selling they must
support the activity of building or
selling or they are waste and to give
you a a a classic example that's been
touted a lot is Steve Jobs the late
great Steve Jobs um was a very good
leader now a lot of people say that he
was tough but say that they did the best
work of their lives when they worked
with him and so it's commonly stated
that Steve Jobs didn't build the iPhone
he built the team that built the iPhone
and this is why it's such a high
leverage skill and this is why it's a
skill that the 0.1% if you look at the
top of the Forbes list all have this
that's fundamentally why it's the third
bucket of the the biggest skills that
generate the most money but if you're
like huh is there any other variable
that dictates how much the 0.1% make
well I'm going to give you the advanced
one which is all of this is multiplied
by risk which is the risk that you're
willing to take on and so whether you're
an employee of a company or you're an
owner of a company there is a risk that
you take on for the building selling and
leading activities that you do that
generate the economic activity that
gives you the percentage of the
production out there if you're willing
to take on more risk this is a
multiplier on all of these skills so if
Steve Jobs and I'll give you Steve Jobs
a perfect
example when Steve Jobs had the company
when it originally went public he owned
15% of the business he ended up leaving
for a period of time starting Pixar and
then he came back like 10 years later
when he came back he was gifted a much
smaller percentage of the company now
here's where it's crazy when he
originally ipoed apple he had 15% if he
had not sold those shares that 15% today
would be worth 465 billion making him by
far the richest man in the world had he
lived to this point and kept his shares
and so the reason that he was never the
richest man in the world is because when
he sold his shares he gave up a lot of
his risk he gave up a lot of his
upside Bill Gates to the same degree
when he ipoed had about 49% of Microsoft
now if Bill Gates had continued to
double down on that risk rather than
selling and diversifying which is what
he did today Bill Gates would be worth 1
and A5 trillion milon dollar he would be
more than a trillionaire but because he
chose to diversify he decreased his risk
and so he got less on the asset that he
owned which was built through building
selling and leading if this video is
helping make things click for you which
is okay I I want to make the most money
humanly possible I want to model the
0.1% and I understand that I have to
build I have to sell I have to lead and
I multiply all of that by the amount of
risk that I'm willing to take on if you
know somebody else in your organization
or you want to share this with your
employees uh it would mean the world to
me because I'm trying to make the world
a better place through economic activity
and uh I believe that fundamentally
every economy in the world could be
super developed if everyone had enough
education and skills so building and
selling that feels relatively
straightforward you learn how to code
you learn how to make a service or you
learn how to advertise you learn how to
sell but how do you learn how to lead
well I think an important part of this
is learning how to orient behavior in a
specific direction that yields the
highest returns and when I say Orient
Behavior I mean the behavior of the
people who work for you or work
alongside you and
the strongest way that I have been able
to get better as a leader is by
eliminating wasted
communication and so what that means is
both internally amongst themselves but
also for me to them and so that means
that I think the vast majority of people
are very in effective communicators is
that they say many words and most of the
times they don't even know what they're
saying I'll give you an example so I had
a director a couple days ago who came up
to me and they wanted to reconcile uh
this director was over you know a
department and they said hey uh you know
one of the people in my team has
basically complained that somebody uh
who's a director report of mine is doing
this issue and so I said and and I'll
tell you the words that um that they
said they said I'm here because I want
to bridge the gap between this
department and this department and I
want to support the growth and the
overall initiatives of the business and
all of those sound like wonderful
corporate words but I I looked at the
the person and I said what do you want
to have happen and they kind of looked
at me differently I said what Behavior
are we currently doing that you would
like us to stop doing or something that
we're currently not doing that you would
like us to start doing and so what's
interesting is that when that question
was posed to the individual they
actually didn't have the answer and so
this is very common is that someone will
know that there is a problem but they
will not come with an intended change in
behavior and so you have to take that
extra next step and say okay there's a
problem what potential changes in
behavior on my team or someone else's
would need to occur in order for us to
decrease the likelihood that this
problem happens again in the future and
so when you frame things from what would
I like to occur what would I like to
have happen as a consequence of this
conversation you'll find that many
conversations don't need to be had to
begin with because most people don't
even Define that and so they basically
just make SP noise at at each other for
30 minutes and call it a meeting but no
one actually changes what they do and so
if you don't change what you do as a
result of communication it was wasted it
literally took effort from both people
time from both people and then no change
occurred and believe it or not this is
the vast majority of people in the vast
majority of companies which is why the
biggest threat to Big organizations is
waste and so if you want to lead you
need to learn how to how to communicate
clearly what you want someone to do what
you want them to stop doing or you want
them to do instead and by defining it in
those terms it cuts away a lot of the
ambiguity I had a meeting not that long
ago with a a different person in in in
the company and I said I don't
understand what you do please explain it
to me now most people you could imagine
would be terrified by this question but
I said I'm not intending to intimidate
you the the point is that I actually
don't understand and I'm seeking seeking
Clarity and so one of the first things
the individual brought up is I I do a
lot of This research so that I can
better understand X Y and Z and I said
what does that change about what we
do and the honest answer was it hadn't
changed anything about what we do and I
said so then if all of this time that
you spend researching doesn't change our
Behavior you don't need to do it it is a
waste of time and so just like I could
measure the temperature in the rooms
when I record them and I could measure
the temperature of every room that I
walk in throughout the day just because
I can measure it doesn't mean it's going
to change anything and so many people
spend a lot of time trying to quote
understand but the only way you will get
a return on that understanding is by
changing what you do and so finally
after several kind of peeling back the
layers I was able to say you do this
this is what you do you click these
buttons you do this stuff okay and then
all of a sudden the scope of what this
person's uh role was went from this to
this and I was like these are the only
things that drive economic activity so
how do we get you to do more of these
things do them faster or do them better
that is the question that we need to
answer together and by doing this it
just it just melts away a lot of the pre
t a lot of the corporate jargon and so
if you get into a conversation with
someone and you don't know what they're
saying don't assume that you're dumb
assume that no one knows what's going on
and I think that if you seek Clarity and
you seek truth then you will ultimately
find the best outcomes rather than
seeking agreement and so we started with
education at technology now we zoomed in
at the second layer of the individuals
what the actual 0.1% wealthiest people
did they zoom in on their skills of
building products that people love being
able to communicate the value of that
products and sell them on buying it and
using it and then leading the team of
people that could help do that at scale
over and over and over again and if
you're like well which one of these
should I start with well everyone starts
on a different BSL path now I personally
started with selling because it's a
chicken and egg issue at the very
beginning you must have something to
sell as soon as you have a basic amount
of something to sell then you must sell
it once you you do this well then you
will have to recruit people to help you
out so then you will learn leadership
and so this tricep will continue to
expand as you get better and better and
better at all three of the tripod skills
so if you're starting from scratch you
first have to figure out what to sell
once you figure out what to sell you
need to learn how to sell it no economic
activity can occur without both of these
things you can't sell nothing and you
can't build and not sell a dollar must
exchange for goods and services so they
have to know about it and you have to
have something to exchange and so
obsessing over your logo and your
branding and your website is neither of
these things unless you're selling the
websites right and so you want to just
start on how do I get people's attention
so that they can give me their contact
information so that I can communicate
with them and explain the value of the
thing I have and then what is required
for me to deliver that thing I have the
first business I ever started I just
gave people my email and my phone number
and then I emailed them personalized
nutrition plans and work out plans so I
had no CRM I had no website I just did
those two things if you are a business
owner at some point your business will
get limited by either the quality of
your product or the product offerings
you have your ability to sell them
meaning you don't have enough people
coming in the door or you have both of
these okay but you can't seem to scale
it because you need more people and so
being able to properly identify which of
these things is the constraint will tell
you where you need to reinvest your time
to get more out of yourself and then
when you do that you expand the lever
and then more money shoots out so how
does build sell lead relate to education
technology well the Ed educational
component is fairly straightforward you
develop the skills around each of these
three but what about technology well if
you can use technology in order to build
more things faster then you will make
more money if the thing that you build
is technological and allows more people
to use it then you will make more money
if somebody builds a table they will
make less money than a developer who
knows how to make an app that a million
people can use because they're able to
provide value at scale just with their
own skill set but it's the skill of
using technology so these things are
very much interwoven with sales sure you
can sell one-on-one but the leveraged
way of doing it is using technology if
you can develop a personal brand and
have trust with a larger audience then
you can sell one to many if you run
advertisements one to many you're using
the technology of the platform and media
so that you can get more people's ATT
ition and then ultimately convert it
from a leadership perspective if you can
track what your employees are doing if
you run a project management systems you
can increase the output per employee by
using Technologies around leadership in
each of these core pillars of value
creation you're going to have the
education to use the technology to
maximize your output per unit of time
and ultimately the money that you make
which is what the 0.1% do and so with
the Advent of things like co-pilot for
coders coders can actually write code 10
times faster than they could before and
so with that as our as our as our our
working model anybody who is not using
technology is always going to be at a
disadvantage and so if you want to be in
the top 0.1% it means you're competing
with everyone and so you want to use as
many advantages as you can and on a
personal note I would say that I have
been someone who's been more hesitant to
use technology and I think that it has
been a limiter to my success and so it's
something that I'm spending more and
more time on of okay how can I
incorporate more technology into the
products and services that we build how
can I incorporate more technology into
how we advertise and sell how can I
incorporate more technology into how we
lead recruit manage people even on the
recruiting side it's like if we can have
Predictive Analytics to figure out which
candidates have higher likelihood of of
matching with the organization and being
good long-term productive employees then
that decreased so much waste for us and
again it increases our output per unit
of time and the coolest thing about
education specifically not necessarily
technology is that when you have these
skills they cannot be taken away they
can't be confiscated they can't be
stolen and this is near and dear to my
heart because uh you know my family uh
was or that we are Iranian um but during
the revolution we left the country and
uh all of our assets were seized and so
in the United States this seems like a
very crazy thing that you could lose
everything overnight but in other
countries this happens all the time the
government just says oh all that money
is ours now all that land is ours now
your house is actually our house now but
the thing is is that the the family
members that I had who had skills and
then were able to scatter all over the
world which my family is uh they were
able to start all over again and rebuild
what they had lost the ones who didn't
have skills and only had the few assets
they had struggled a
lot and still du to this day so the
first layer was Global and we figured
out education technology underneath of
Education technology it's like where we
investing that education technology
technology around building education
around Building Technology around
selling education around selling
technology around leadership education
around leadership and so in each of
those settings if we invest in them the
lever expands and more money shoots out
the other side and so the final layer is
environmental so BSL creates the money
and then that money is either wasted so
it goes off the map it's stored meaning
it basically stays the same or what the
top 0.1% do is it's multiplied and the
way that they multiply it is they either
buy stuff or they lend so you can only
do two things with money you can give it
to people and then they give you a
little bit more of it back in the form
of debt or you buy stuff with it that
either goes up in value sometimes it can
go down but the hope is that it goes up
in value and it produces an output so an
example of the storage would be I buy a
brick of gold a brick of gold does
nothing and it's speculative in that we
hope that somebody else in the future
will pay us more for that brick of gold
and no matter what currency I have I can
trade gold for euros I can trade gold
for for for Bitcoin I can trade gold for
US Dollars it doesn't matter it's a
store of value and as far as we've had
in human history people still value gold
now you could take all of the gold in
the world and this is a waren Buffett
example you could take all the gold in
the world and put it in the middle of a
baseball field and it would be about as
tall as the stadium and be a big round
Globe it doesn't matter what you do to
that big ball of gold a 100 years from
now it'll still be a big ball of gold
but if you took that same amount of
economic
value and then you put it you would be
and you invested it through buying you
could buy all the Farmland in the United
States and about 13 Exon mobils and so
the amount of money that those farms and
Exxon Mobile would spit out every single
year over that 100 years would be at
least greater than zero and so in that
way this is how this Loop of wealth gets
spun and so when you are buying or
lending you're either lending to people
who are doing BSL and the risk that you
incur is that they don't actually
succeed and you never get your money
back you're compensated for the risk
based on the interest that you charge
for them so you basically sell them
money for more money
later with buying the assets what you're
doing is you're buying a percentage or
the entirety of their build sell lead
now if you recall
earlier I said this is all multiplied by
risk this is where that money goes you
take on that risk and and so as a result
you get to have an outsized percentage
of what other people are doing to build
sell and lead and then this gives you
even more
money over time and so in understanding
this this is why I built acquisition.
comom the way I did which is we have
these companies that generate money and
then that money either goes back into
the company to make it a bigger company
or it goes into buying another company
that generates money but then this
process repeats itself over and over and
over again and it compounds unto itself
so no matter how big you get you can
keep reinvesting all of that money and
then it's a percentage-based growth so
whether it's a million dollars growing
by 10% or a billion dollars growing by
10% you're still growing 10% but the
absolute amount of what that 10% is is
$100,000 versus is $100 million and so
if you're the individual you can take
this money and you can invest it in
people who are going to do build sell
lead in your company where you take on
more risk which means that you get
outsize Returns on the investment in the
people that's within an organization you
can buy a slice of an organization of
all of those people and not have to
necessarily do anything that's what the
public markets are more or less all
about or investment funds do or at the
most micro level you could just take
that money and invest it in yourself by
buying skills and what does buying
skills even mean it means you pay
someone to give you feedback on an
activity such that you can replicate the
outcome that they can already do
fundamentally that's what buying skills
is and so you find someone who has the
skill that you want and then you offer
them money so that you can continue to
do the activity in front of them until
eventually you replicate the outcome
that they have because they have taught
you the variables that they use to
recreate that skill and once you can do
it without them and get the same outcome
than you have learned and so if we're
thinking about this in terms of levels
you can have a piece of a
company you can have people that you
hire in a
company
or you can put that money into yourself
but all three of these are going to
relate to BSL build sell lead and to
what
degree is the risk that you take on so
buying a piece of a company would be
probably higher risk a little bit less
risk would be bringing somebody in and
paying them the lowest risk is going to
be investing in yourself but here's
where it gets kind of interesting is
that when you invest in yourself this
can also give you all of the skills that
you need to do all of these things
better which is why and I will continue
to hit this until the day I die you will
always be the best investment and so you
want to max out this bucket to the
greatest degree possible and the
limitation that you will have when you
do reinvest in yourself is the time it
takes to learn the skills and how many
skills you can learn but at any given
time you should always be spending as
much money as you can to buy the most
valuable skill that is constraining your
growth and so if you look at build you
look at sell you look at lead you figure
out the one that's limiting you the most
and you put as much cash into that thing
as you can you pay every expert you
possibly know or don't know or need to
know in order to get what you need to
move forward if I could isolate one
decision that has changed my life
forever was the willingness to invest my
money in the potential to learn a skill
from someone who is further ahead than
me and I I will probably do that till
the day I die because I have gotten
better Returns on that money than
anything else in the world and if you
enjoyed this video on what the 0.1%
wealthiest people invest their time and
money into then you're going to love the
video that I made on leverage it's the
number one video on my channel it's
basically how to go through a wealth
warp of time it was one of the first
presentations I made before I became
public basically a consolidation of many
of the thoughts that I had that created
the generational wealth that my wife and
I have been able to experience I hope
you enjoy it